all of a sudden this the story about
Charlie's Angels resurfaces it was so
weird it just popped up and asks about
you yeah I'm one of those people that I
can't sweep anything under the car I
can't either good let's do it let's talk
so apparently the story is that when you
came in
um to meet with us on Charlie's Angels
um we were doing chemistry reads with
lots of people yeah and I just called my
partner Nan
um we've been in flower films together
for 30 years actually remember her she
loves you I know because well I don't
know that but I remember feeling the
love and I was like this is so bizarre
so apparently a producer called your
agent and said something to the effect
of
eyebrows and it was the eyes what was it
tell us what happened just so so here's
what happened I go and I audition I'm
first of all so excited to meet you
and I'm excited to meet you and I really
loved you and it went really well and
I'll tell you what I think the real
reason is but I'll first set the story
up for you so I go in I audition then
you go home and you wait and you hope to
get the response which is you're going
to get the job I didn't get the job it's
okay it happens but the feedback was my
eyebrows were too sophisticated and I
looked too old next to Drew
and that was the feedback and I was like
what it just was an odd way of saying
you didn't get the job and so now that
I'm older and wiser and we've been in
this business for a long time I think
what was happening during that time is
there were all these conversations about
diversity but people weren't really
pulling the trigger I don't think this
has anything to do with you or your
partner or your film company I think
this is just a result of the fear of
really putting a black woman into a film
that never cast anyone black it was a
first time for them there was this
initiative to cast more black women have
more black women on set but Hollywood
wasn't quite doing it because I remember
during that time
I actually auditioned for so many roles
that weren't written black to the point
where I was exhausted it was almost like
bring the black girls in bring the black
actors in so we can say that we did it
but we're not going to necessarily pull
the trigger so what I will say now is
things have changed a little I thank God
for producers like you because I know
you're aware and you're and you're
sensitive to it because you're having
the conversation absolutely and it was
always yeah
well
Nan and I
um really cared about we almost felt
nervous and bad if you will yeah when it
was me and Cameron we were like oh God
that doesn't feel right for us but it
was so good and the original Charlie's
Angels were all you know white for women
but they look different
um they you know hair color wise maybe
yeah not really I mean there was no
diversity there no let's call that out
let's just say and we felt the exact
opposite and this was in 1999 when those
conversations were not being had and it
was really her and I who championed the
fact that like okay we love our Angels
so far but now what yeah and when we
even went in to present ourselves as
producers for the film all of our
pitches for the combination of the trio
all had diversity in it and that was
just something that felt right in our
guts at the time
and it's it's bewildering to me that
someone would say those things it
doesn't make any sense Nan and I would
never talk about
eyebrows done for me I'm sure what women
would do no women don't talk about
things like that and I'm and I'm 101
positive that it came from a studio exec
that has no concept and understanding of
the importance of diversity let alone
what you stand for because you've been
in this game Drew for a very long time
and I know your heart and I see your
show and I know who you are so this was
never anything that I took personal at
all but I'm glad we're having the
conversation because black women and
white women women period we need to talk
we need to stay in communication because
at the end of the day it's hard for all
women in this industry I don't care what
who you are it's harder for us there's
less roles there's less diversity but if
we don't talk to each other then we can
next have a show and create something
with each other absolutely we have to
keep the dialogue going and so that's I
appreciate you and being brave enough to
with me to have this conversation of
course I mean I was mortified when I
heard it because Nana and I would never
speak like that and as far as age that's
the stupidest thing because you're
actually the same exact number and age
as Lucy Liu so how is that possible and
I grew up in an industry where I was
like I will not fall prey to anti to
aging and all that BS like that will
never be my thing I watch too many
people suckle off the Fountain of Youth
and think they were less worthy if they
looked older so age and Weight and Body
I was like this is a toxic part of this
industry oh my God one many wonderful
things about it but this part I will not
play with and I will not succumb to so
there's no way the age thing was an
issue yeah
[Music]